what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
Pearl daily where I cover this week's
treachery debauchery and craziness
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos like
the video on your way in as that is the
most important metric that YouTube uses
to push out these streams also while
you're at it guys get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today as you guys
know all of the world's craziness and
debauchery really started when women
thought they were equal to men and were
given the right to vote help me move the
Overton window by normalizing this
thought process get yourself a women
shouldn't vote t-shirt today at the
audacity network. store that's the
audacity network. store today I have a
special guest on the show Welcome
Christine
hello Christine is a our talent here at
the YouTube Network the audacity Network
here at the audacity Network indeed you
should go check out my Channel at
Christine Grace Smith and I also discuss
the treachery Deery of today's society
but more trying to tell you the things
that the mainstream media doesn't want
you to know so if that sounds like
something you'd be into go check out
yeah you just saidit 25k I did yeah
thank you so much yeah keep growing it's
amazing I call you my conspiracy theory
chick yeah I the the specific compliment
you gave me the other day is actually
the best compliment I've ever gotten in
my life so yeah I'm running with that
yeah like I say Alex Jones is like her
guy
cuz I could tell you about the history
of feminism but I'm like if I want to
know something about conspiracy theories
I even know about MK Ultra I'll tell you
yeah yeah it's you you and Nazarene both
guys Rachel Wilson is another one have
you talked to her yeah yeah 100% so
today a lot of my topics get inspired by
Twitter as you know okay I'm a big
Tweeter really I'm no way which go
follow me on Twitter pearly things with
a z um so there was a woman that decided
to tweet her dating
history I know I know let's pull it up
let's pull it up a politician Finance
Finance Finance 64 engineer business
founder Finance doctor engineer company
founder artist CEO surgeon not not sure
never said 64 go to the next one I think
it keeps going more I think it keeps
going Finance corporate lawyer doctor
business founder politician model
Finance investment Baker surgeon
University Professor data analyst 65
pilot pilot she's been with oh my gosh
oh it keeps going I thought we were
done oh okay investment banker
bioengineer ran a startup Professor
surgeon Finance corporate lawyer
politician NGO researcher aristoc
Aristocrat engineer Pol politician
investment banker wow okay I count like
48 I think count 48 was it that many I
think so I I might have counted wrong so
I think there's a couple things that I
find interesting one obviously the
number is crazy yeah two you know there
used to be a sense of Shame about these
types of things you know I actually know
someone in London I could tell you after
where this guy actually married an ex-
stripper and he was a famous guy okay
and he didn't know that she was a
stripper before Oh gosh now I'm not
justifying this but women used to have
like a sense of Shame yeah they at least
knew like this is right this is wrong
it's probably wrong to date 48 men yeah
that's probably that's a lot yeah do you
know what I mean like and now we're at a
point where they're they're bragging
about it yeah I just I don't understand
the mindset also what just irks me is I
really hate people who air out their
diet laundry so like she's doing it as
as you say as a way to brag but I don't
see it like that I see it as you're
airing out your dirty laundry cuz you're
just showing like how many people have
said no to you it's like you think that
this is making you look really good
actually that's just showing that with
48 encounters you've still not managed
to find success with someone yeah and
it's also like they're dating down
that's what's happened I don't know what
she looks like but I'm just assuming
she's a normal looking chick and you're
talking to and it almost ruins the women
for their husbands because because how
are how is any guy going to measure up
to the surgeon and what was her reason
for posting this does she say like why
wait go back to go back to the first one
king oh just dating history yeah wow
Finance CEO yeah she's really cheating
herself here because you know how many
men are over 6 foot that's a small
percentage in itself how many men are
going to be surgeons doctors politician
like these are very you know not
everyone can have these jobs and in fact
the majority of people aren't going to
be in these type of jobs so she's
actually slimming down her chances one
by showing the world that 48 times she
still can't find success two by airing
out her dirty laundry that's that's
unattractive no one's going to want that
in a partner and three how many people
like you say are going to be able to
live up to that well and it's really
competitive too it's interesting to see
The Bachelor have you ever watched The
Bachelor um you you don't have that here
in the US like um okay The Bachelorette
have you heard of it I think it's I
think I know what it is is it kind of
like like Jord Shaw kind okay okay
basically they have a guy or a girl and
then a bunch of men and a bunch of women
come to compete to like marry them
usually at the end okay yeah we those
kind of show yeah usually at the end
someone proposes so um I remember there
was a I think his name was Matt and
Rachel um so there was a season where
there was a guy named Matt and he was
like a 64 investment banker Jack and
it's interesting cuz you actually see
the real competition for these men right
because you you literally see all the
women that are applying to be these guys
girlfriend right and you see like 50
women that come to these things that are
beautiful they're fit feminine friendly
I mean obviously they throw a couple
crazy chicks in there good yeah
obviously but you see in real time how
competitive it is and to end up with one
of the guys that she's talking about
like you have to compete yeah yeah yeah
yeah and women today don't see it as a
competition no because they think
they're the prize exactly and so it's
kind of like she had 48 job interviews
and hasn't managed to keep one exactly
and maybe it's like maybe you have a
maybe maybe you have a high school
diploma and you're applying for like a a
professor position or something yeah
yeah this is a list of the men she effed
somebody tell her that dating is
something else I'm go to the next one
that's a good point it's very
instinctual how women always refer to
the men they've dated by their job title
oh I didn't even think about that that
is very telling that's a really good
Insight it's almost like she refers to
the guys based on what she valued about
them and what they bring for her what's
important her yeah because the other
ones she said job titles but the tall
guys she just said 6'4 true yeah haha
she has a list of professions and then
just 65 for one of these guys what a
blessing to a guy to be born tall right
yeah um is that
Nina and and the thing is you know she
can attract this level of guy in her 20s
but what what are her 30s going to be
like exactly and then this is why the
men get so frustrated dating women in
their 30s you know I've actually talked
to guys where they they say you know I
don't even it's not about looks right
it's not even a looks thing why we don't
date women in their 30s now that's cap a
little bit obviously but you can of get
some
somewhat attractive but what they say is
by the time they're in their 30s their
standards have gotten so high that's it
most women are in debt most of them
haven't been doing anything in their
stuck in their ways yes and so they meet
the girl in their 30s you have to get on
her program and she has this High List
of Demands because of all these men
she's dated in her 20s yeah yeah yeah
yeah you know and the thing as you get
older you start to Sag but you wouldn't
sag as much if you knew that one of the
leading reasons skin begins to Sag and
form wrinkles is not necessarily because
of old age but because our bodies are
missing out on essential collagen you
see we produce 10% less collagen every
decade once we hit 30 and that's a major
reason behind those pesty wrinkles
that's why myself along with tens of
thousands of people have turned this
Cutting Edge new substance to help
reduce visible signs of aging it uses
the top five most research types of
collagen which is essential for skin
Health to support skin elasticity and
skin hydration the best part is you get
53% off for the rest of the month or
until they sell out whichever comes
first get yours now by going to health
with pearl.com that's Health withth
pearl.com you won't regret it it's
interesting to see the level of like
savagery that these young kids are doing
right like they've been watching the
internet for so long oh yeah that they
have just learned to roast from like the
youngest age 100% 100% um so I saw a
clip of a 15-year-old destroying chicks
on a podcast similar to like whatever
fresh and Fit I think I know he we're
going to pull it up I thought it was so
funny I didn't know that I was going to
be sitting talking to a bunch of
illiterate people who don't know how to
read you're literally 15 what do you
know you know how to read yes I do know
how to read name 10 books are you
serious yes 100% name 10 books well I
read Game of Thrones I'm obsessed with
like the Twilight
series Game of Thrones the series what's
what's the book called It's not called
Game of Thrones she's just trying to
come up with a bunch of nonsense and she
can't name any actual books bro shut up
kid B you're changing the subject
actually three books three books okay
well the Game of Thrones series book I
want the name it is a book it is a book
no but I want the name of the book I'll
Google the book right now you want to
show that neate the that negate the
point let me show let me show you this
Ser since you don't you don't believe me
I I'll show you since you don't believe
the book is called The Song of Ice and
Fire now before you embarrass yourself
by looking up the name of a book she
couldn't even actually name a single
book she doesn't know how to read she's
clearly illiterate like where do these
kids come from it is hilarious though it
is so fny it is hilarious because she
she is making a bit of a TI of herself
like oh like I think it would have gone
over better if she's like look I'm not a
big reader you know be honest it's the
fact that she's so insistent and she
can't believe the fact that there is any
possibility on this Earth that he could
one be right because you know he's
pointing out the fact that her life
choices means that she's just basically
an internet she doesn't want to
accept that and also she doesn't want to
accept the fact that someone who's
younger than her could be smaller than
her let's look at the comments here we
have she's saying you're just 15 and
then pulls out the reading list of a
10-year-old girl yeah yeah oh no she
tried to bring him down for her ignorant
level and beat him with experience it
failed miserably her t-shirt told her
reality and background without even
that's what made it even better is it
said por star on her
shirt do you think that selling your
nudes online and like do you think the
money that you make from that translates
to any sort of intelligence or skill or
do you accept the fact that you have no
skill and maybe lack a lot of
intelligence which is why you had to go
down that path that is not I had to go
down that path I have a degree a degree
in what philosophy you could have become
a very well-respected lawyer had a good
career what do you think your kids are
going to think when they said oh my mom
had two options they could have been a
philosopher and a lawyer who made a lot
of money but they decided to be an
online home for 2 years and then when
they got ugly now nobody wants to hire
them anymore because they ruined their
name and their
reputation she didn't even know what to
say that's the thing it's like I would
have so much more respect for these
women if they could at least acknowledge
the the facts of their choices yeah like
if she could just say like yeah like you
know this is the choice I made to me it
was more important to have money
straight away and I don't really care
about working and I don't have a good
work ethic that's why I'm not willing to
go down the path of becoming a lawyer I
would go wow Fair play like you
you you live that life and you accept
the facts of it exactly but instead they
want to say there's no consequences
that's that's what it just drives me mad
it's like the thing is it's always like
you know people will always come for
people like you and you know I'm only at
25k so no doubt they'll come for me soon
but the the point is is that like they
come after people like us and they say
oh you're you're you're judging and
you're putting yourself on a pedestal
and all of this and d d d it's like no
no no no no no no we're just asking to
live in a world of Truth yeah cuz that's
the most important thing to me it's like
what is true what's true and they want
to lie to women so like they just
they're constantly putting lies on T
that's actually not kind it's not that's
not kind to lie to people and to say
that it's okay to live in delusion and
that it's okay to to live in a lack of
accountability and and and lack of
regard for reality because ultimately
that only leads down a path of
Destruction so it's actually a lot
kinder to admit the truth of things even
if the truth makes you feel bad cuz I'm
sure her saying look I I don't have the
work ethic or the ability to strive to
be a lawyer I'm sure that would probably
make her feel a bit about herself
but the truth is she then protects other
people from having to go down that route
cuz people can then think think about it
well and then you can kind of adapt
accordingly like if you're important I
don't expect any guy to take care of you
the rest of your life if it if it
happens it happens great but the odds
are not in your favor you probably will
not be happily married so develop a plan
and act accordingly I I saw a video the
other day of like a 92-year-old
um ex like um hooker okay it was so
weird to see this old lady like talk
about all those right
she used to do it was so
funny um and it was sort of like the way
she was talking was so different than
how the younger women talk because she
sort of was just like yeah I was a
yeah there wasn't no am I was I know
she's like yep I did what I did there
were consequences that is it that's
exactly right it's all good when we are
young and have the goods but when you
are no longer wanted as a nude you will
have to return to real life but your
nudes are out there still what employer
will hire you what man will date you a
man doesn't want all of his friends
looking at his girlfriend's nudes and
the other issue that I think we get you
do get women that it works out for I'm
going to give you a couple examples so
Kim Kardashian was a famous rapper's
wife and how many times on the show do
bring up Kim cette all the time
and they see it work out for them and
they they look at the exception but they
don't look at the rule and even the
exception it still doesn't work out for
them long term no because long term they
still end up by themselves because
they're too damaged to stay in the
relationship Kim Kardashian will die
alone now I is she really going to be
miserable as a
billionaire me I don't know that's
specul you have worse problems yeah
exactly but but my point is that is not
what is going to happen to the average
chick the average chick will lit
literally die alone yeah which is why
it's it's not kind to not take
accountability for the circumstances of
your life because then other people will
see that and think that they can do the
same and then it's just a cycle that
repeats well and think about the average
only fans model makes less than $500 a
month the average only fans model makes
less than the average McDonald's
employee no way wow I never even thought
of that so I think it's in the states
that that statistic is from I think it's
in the states the average fans model
makes uh less than $15 an hour and I
think that's about the average the
average wage for a McDonald's employee
wow but it's that idea of it's not
actually about money they always use
this cope that oh I needed money or they
they'll make up some reason why they
were in these positions that all that
was the last thing they could resort to
and it's like no no no no no you're
missing out the part where you say you
don't want to work the issue is you
don't want to have to go and work an
eight hour shift well I think that women
would do it for free I think they would
do it for attention women do look at
their Instagrams yeah yeah and this is
the but they look at Kim Kardashian and
Kim Kardashian got money Fame she got
all of this stuff she got high net worth
individuals wanting to marry her and
it's like for every one Kim Kardashian
there is there's what a thousand women
that it doesn't work out for or even um
what what's her face like call her daddy
s do you know who that is Alex Cooper
she basically put her sex life on the
internet and she's getting married but
she's yeah like she there's no sex tapes
or anything but she had like a podcast
with another chick where they said
really runchy stuff and that's the
problem she got 50 million for it okay
maybe that was a good tradeoff debatable
debatable but you could you could at
least see the argument but most chicks
do that for free so they said if they're
upset about it they can cry in one of
their four Ferraris none of these
are good do any of them look
like they have any business say you
think they know how to add like okay how
Petty of everyone in the comment section
to shame a woman they don't know
personally I mean why the hell do we
have to judge someone for their personal
choices when we ourselves don't like to
be judged she made her choice and she
has every right to as a human being
having morals is one thing but expecting
the other person to have lived the way
you're living is just a petty way to
establish you are superior in every way
one thing that I don't like shame comes
from within
I it it's so interesting when you see
interviews where one person's trying to
shame the other yes and they're just
like yeah so nobody can make you feel
shame no you you it comes from within so
you can't blame other people for the way
that you feel exactly only you control
how you feel and it's like when you know
women get asked about their body count
and then they they get all like funny
about it and then they say oh like I'm
not ashamed it's like well clearly you
are and also no one is is saying saying
that by having things like shame and the
concept of Tolerance and all these
different things no one is saying that
that's about establ establishing any
kind of dominance over anyone to say
that you are superior in one way or
another it's just having a universal
code of truth that means we all adhere
to a code of Truth where we can all
acknowledge what we've done in our lives
it is true no one likes to feel shame
but like you say the first point is you
only feel shame if you decide to feel
shame and if it if it bothers you you
will feel shame and the second point to
be made is that no one is saying that
this woman in this video has to have
lived how the 15-year-old boy is saying
or even like the way that we are saying
because we we would say yeah you
probably should have gone down the
lawyer route and no one is saying that
what we're saying is correct we are just
saying that if you are going to go down
a path you have to own it that's it and
it's the fact that every opportunity
they get they try and cope out of it he
says you could have been this why didn't
you and instead of her just being honest
and saying I didn't because of this this
and this and this is my choice and I'm
proud of it and you know you can you can
respect that at least she knows where
she's at it's the fact that she goes
straight to but I am I am intelligent I
have a degree and it's like she
obviously feels shame in herself if she
feels the need to have to say she is
something I've noticed this pattern in
so many people who come on the show they
constantly feel the need to tell the
room what they are I'm this I'm that
like you know I'm I'm a good person how
how often do we hear that you know I'm
intelligent I've got a degree how often
do we hear that you know and and also
another one I hear all the time is uh
like oh I I'm just real about things or
um wow I never thought about that and
it's like if someone has to tell you
what they are chances are they're not
the smartest people I know never say
that they're smart you know they never
like CU I think of my I I think of the
smartest people I know are like
literally my dad and my brother Adam and
even Austin's really like my brother's
really and I've never heard them say
that they're smart because when you ask
when you tell a smart person that
they're smart or like say you're so
smart they kind of are like oh whatever
cuz they know people smarter than them
yes you know yeah yeah yeah and it's
like the person in the room who
constantly feels the need to say what
they are is saying that because it's a
projection of the fact that they're not
so they project it outwards and they say
this is what I am because the inside
like this is just psychoanalysis whether
they're conscious of this or not is a
different issue but the the the truth is
at least from what I've seen it's they
can't feel it in themselves so they feel
a need to have to say it cuz at least
that way if they convin if they can
convince other people of it that
validates what they're missing yeah cuz
the people that always say this is one
I've noticed I'm so
real they're never real no they're never
real or or um I I I'm a what is it it's
always something like or I'm a I'm a
traditional woman they never look
tradition because traditional women I
mean they're rare anyways but it's like
the one trait they have is
humility and they're always thinking
well I could be better you know and
that's the thing it's like people that
are actually skilled in something are
always I don't need to say that they are
no and typically they know people that
are better than them because that's who
they're around like the most traditional
women are around the most traditional
women the smartest men are around the
smartest men so they're always reminded
that they are not the smartest person or
it's like if you if you have a job that
say the example that comes to mind is
for example a surgeon do you think a
surgeon walks into the room and feels
the need to tell everyone that he saves
lives absolutely not because every day
people thank him for saving their lives
whereas you have something else I don't
know say just like a a mundane normal
job a normal person job if that person
really feels unfulfilled in their job I
can guarantee you that they go around
telling people that you know I I I save
lives in this job or do this or they
find some way to make out that what they
do is so important ultimately the only
reason they do that is because it's not
fulfilling them in the way that it needs
to when people are fulfilled they don't
feel the need to spread to the rest of
the world what they have because they
already had it have it why do you need
to project what you have if you already
are that or yeah or like people that
brag about money are the same way they
never have money so many people come on
the show and they say like you know like
I'm quite well off or I do this or or
like you know I get this I get that
realize that we can Google their
companies I
know
like okay so you know I got a lot of
heat because I said basically you
getting heat never never never I say
that basically women's jobs are pretty
much useless correct now again there are
exceptions now I always say I use ianka
Trump as an example I a Donald Trump's
daughter right I would imagine she's
better at business than a lot of people
being raised by a trump of course
imagine I don't actually know too much
about her maybe she doesn't do you just
assume by association that she would be
yeah and there's women that are super
smart like the same way you have
children right and in general adults are
smarter than children yeah but
occasionally you'll get a child prodigy
that's amazing it's it's phen you can't
even believe you can't even believe
they're a kid I feel the same way about
women yeah no I feel like by and large
men are smarter occasionally you get a
female Prodigy that is really smart but
Al the same way the smartest adults are
always
smarter than children the smartest men
are always going to be smarter than
women yeah and but I came to this
conclusion that a lot of women's jobs
are useless and the reason I came to
this conclusion was I started thinking
about women's sports you know I play
volleyball here and I know that women's
sports always operates at a loss and
it's funny I I was arguing actually with
a couple of my teammates about this I
swear I was arguing with some of my
teammates on the way um to our game last
weekend and they were saying how there
were profitable women's leagues places
and I was saying no no no they're not
and I was saying if women if women's
leagues are profitable it's always
because of either drama sexuality or
male investors subsidizing it being nice
basically in the same way actually I
found an investor for our team and they
did it to be nice wow exact like you
make this up and and I was telling
them that they basically don't know what
they're talking about and I was thinking
like you know I actually run shows so I
have to think about what would be
profitable and I've literally thought
about how can I make just because I
really like my coaches I think they're
nice people I try to help them out when
I can so I've thought about how can we
make our league more profitable because
all the players have to play or pay to
sign up and the idea is typically you
get picked up by like a European team
okay so it it's like and which was what
I was going to do until you know this
all whatever and basically like they
really believed that and I was I was
comparing women's sports to charity work
right well it essentially is isn't it
because they they need the outside help
to do anything and I thought about the
WNBA with the WNBA does is it takes the
top guys say here's our charity work
women's sports we're going to take pay
from the men yeah and give it to the
women and I thought about how this
probably happens where men's wages are
being stolen from by women mhm but the
men don't even know it because it's not
their decision right and what I thought
about was in Corporate America the
before and after of Twitter yes so the
before picture there was a bunch of
women there there's a bunch it was like
half women and then when the rubber met
the road and they said oh we need
to cut our expenses so we can make money
which resulted in a lot of women losing
their jobs yeah the women were the ones
that went because they're not doing the
actual work and now the company is
innovating yes and what backed up this
claim also was that I would see these
women with their what I do in a day oh
at Tik Tok yeah yeah yeah and it was
always like well I went to a meeting and
then I got my latte and then so I'm
thinking maybe they're not really doing
that much work and I think this is
everywhere I think and again yes there
are exception even in Twitter you know
it's
funny I was I was not surprised at all
there was like five chicks that made it
like that was it and it was anyways but
there was a couple chicks that made it
they're hard workers whatever so okay my
thought is I think this just goes on in
society it says this is the reason I
think that to back up this claim even
further
25% of Iceland's population went on
strike mostly women okay which you also
see when we go by the hospital it's
always women protesting right so 25% of
Iceland's population went on strike and
nobody even noticed let's pull up the
video
[Music]
video like did you hear about that no I
want to know what it is that they're
fighting for they're fighting for
equality but what okay what do you mean
what you well if they were not have if
they were so needed why didn't the
economy tank
right I mean you could look at any
business right it just looks like an
excuse to have a street party in my
opinion like like you could look at any
business if people didn't show up to
work starts to go south absolutely
you notice it like 25% of bloody loal
workers and even 25% of the staff it
would be like oh yeah and they
didn't even
notice so this further backs up my claim
yeah that I really do think the majority
of women have useless jobs well yeah
well they had to invent a bunch of
useless jobs because they had all these
women who wanted to work they're not
going to put these women in say jobs
that need to be done by men for the sake
of society not collapsing so they had to
invent a bunch of useless jobs human
resources Human Resources project
manager correct and Twitter's health and
what is it uh diversity and inclusion
diversity and inclusion there's another
one as well it's the uh the one that was
censoring all the people on Twitter that
was all women like 80 90% women yeah so
the you know Rachel Wilson yes yeah
friend of the show she comments on this
and says people have raged against me
and pearly things for saying that the
world would actually be fine if women
didn't go to work well it actually
happened and we were right no no body
gave a plus Iceland was already
Ultra egalitarian epic patriarchy W yep
the next comment says and you know
what's interesting just to add to that
in egalitarian societies where the like
access to equal opportunity is a lot
more equal the women tend to do more
feminine jobs and the men tend to do
more masculine jobs and actually the
separation between the Sexes is much
greater so that actually just reinforces
what you're saying because that means
those women chances are they were in
very much women's jobs so it's it's not
like it's not the same as saying over
here if 25% of the population went on
strike because over here you know you
you've got more women in in masculine
sectors but that just shows you that
these women are women who would have
been in likely feminine positions and
even with them disappearing like nothing
nothing changed no one noticed do you
know what else too I was reading some of
the early anti-suffragist writings yeah
did you know they equated women voting
to communism because sense yeah because
they said it indicates that it's the
vote of the individual and not the vote
of the family yeah it's it's the family
yeah and I never even thought about that
it that's it's more communism course
like I never even thought about that
it's Marxism and communism at its core
because it's the idea that the family is
this oppressive unit and the idea that
we we we have to be all of these
individuals in a pot rather than having
like family units that
derived from hierarchies it's it's
ultimately the destruction of a
hierarchy which is Marxist and communist
at its core so they said women deserve
the Liberty to go to work if they want
and denying them this is evil most women
would be happier at home if women left
the job market and pass pay would
Skyrocket for men allowing Mo most
families to live comfortably on one
income both are true at the same time I
never even I never even say that women
should be banned from the workforce
except in police officers that Hill I
will die on get them out of the oil rigs
get him out of the yeah and the SAS yeah
that that Hill I will die on but what's
hilarious is that with the with the SAS
thing in particular I think they're
making it it's either happened or it's
going to happen uh where women can can
you know join the SAS but the thing is
is that to join the SAS um that's the
the special forces in the UK um so like
the top of the top like the people who
are in this group you you have to be a
specific type of human being to get into
that group it doesn't really make a
difference for the SAS because it's like
we can say oh yeah women come along and
join they won't pass the training they
won't make it no but they lower it for
them that's what they did in the US they
they won't they as far as from what I
know from someone who who knows quite a
lot about this um they won't for the SAS
they might for the Army and they might
for the police but because the SAS is
such a high up thing I don't think they
will yeah hopefully if they do we're
really well and it takes away from the
women that actually pass those
requirements yes when there's quotas
because then people just assume she's
just there because she's a woman and
then you have incompetent people in
positions of power exactly women can
marry the government but they don't see
the government as the actual patriarchy
they blame men under the same system who
were raised by single mothers married to
the government yes uh probably the most
peaceful day men have had in
Century oh can you imagine they were
able to go back to their old school
banter they were able to have a laugh
they were able to say what they thought
without worrying about a woman listening
they're like thank God these chicks are
outy that's the thing I don't think
women realize how much they police men's
speech I was talking about this on an
interview yesterday we did an interview
for the audacity Network me and Shahara
with a guy called Mike Bell um he's the
founder of a an appg in the UK and he
talks about men's rights and we was
talking about the fact that men don't
have men's spaces anymore there's more
than enough women's spaces there's more
than enough places that are just for
women in most gyms you've got areas that
are women only you know you don't have
any men's only gyms in the UK there's a
women's Minister there's no men's
Minister and even in jobs where they
were predominantly before mostly men
women have now infiltrated those spaces
and what happens is men can't talk how
men talk even in places like the fire
brigade you know you got women
firefighters come in men are used to
having a particular type of banter and
and they can't when the women are around
and I think it's it's what me and you
have had this conversation before most
women haven't heard how men talk when
women aren't around the locker room talk
so when they do hear it it triggers them
and they make a problem out of it but
it's like you know I I sort of I I
mentioned this on the interview I I sort
of it really irks me and I want to shake
these women sometimes and be like do you
not think your dad your granddad oh yeah
your brother has said stuff that if you
heard in another room you would be
shocked course unless not act innocent
it's not like women don't say things to
each other that if the men heard they
would be shocked too we totally have
locker room talk this this guy toally
yeah exact this guy Mike Bell made made
a very very funny Point what was it he
said um men men insult each other and
don't mean it but women compliment each
other and uh don't mean it I was just
like that is so true yeah that is so
true yeah and that's what that's what
frustrates me is then like the women go
to HR and they cry and do all this stuff
and I'm like okay you've asked to be in
a man's world and I know some tough ass
women I know some women that don't do
this and they're they're just
tough women you know what's interesting
in the 1900s they actually had the same
like women have been policing men's
speech even before like media they're in
the workforce they would try to police
men's like bars oh that doesn't yeah
like the 1900s there's like writings of
them trying to get yeah it's like the
men are just like leave us alone
let us have a laugh the thing that's the
point like men don't mean half the
things they say yeah yeah and that's the
bad things they say but it's like women
don't mean the good things they say so
we don't even have a leg to sound on
yeah and come on guys like I'm like okay
if you recorded women's Locker like I
grew up an athlete like women talk very
runchy when it's not in like a public I
like come on guys there's not stuff you
said you you're God you've never said
anything behind the scenes inappropriate
come on like get out of my face so there
is a video going viral right now and it
was this woman with a small amount of
subscribers she had one video that just
took off and it was titled I'm a
33-year-old woman with no life this is
my advice to young women okay and the
reason I think it's important is because
it kind of highlights everything that I
just kind of touched on it brings it
together okay so this woman eventually
got divorced now she's unemployed in her
30s with no kids wow and the reason it
went so viral is it resonates with
people well that's why things do go
viral exactly that's that's the thing
like people think you could just make
up and it'll go viral no now you
have to connect with people and you can
figure out what's going on in society by
figuring out what is going viral in
women's songs what is going viral in
female YouTubers because people want
people they can relate to yes especially
female influencers so let's pull it up I
am a 33y old woman with no direction in
life and I want to talk about it I will
give you some advice at the end of how
to deal with this and cope with no sense
of direction but for now I kind of just
want to tell you my story of how I got
here and it's not long and it's not that
sad and it's not like I'm not going to
try to make you cry when I was maybe
late to my 20s to like college age I had
a vision in my head of what I wanted out
of my life of what my life was going to
be like when I reached the age I'm at
now and some of the things I wanted were
okay of course I was going to graduate
college which I did thank God and then I
was going to get married I got married
and then divorced there's more to that
story but that's for another video I
wanted a big career I started having a
nice okay career and then that pummeled
again I can talk about that later
but that's how my life has been so up
and down that I no longer know what I
want even though I've planned this life
since I was really young and then when I
graduated college I had an internship
which is again that's pretty normal you
graduate college you get an internship I
got a really good internship when I was
in college I studied video production I
studied um basically a very interesting
version of Journalism and I wasn't I
didn't know I wanted to be in journalism
but um I knew for sure that I didn't
want to
tell like sad story so I didn't really
aim to do journalism but that's what
basically my major was that's what I
studied and I gradu that I did I was an
okay student you know I got an
internship for digital media coordinator
and and that went really well and then I
was like okay this is good I I graduated
college I got an
internship this is life is going to be
good life is going to be good and
then I never got
jobs that's when I was around maybe 23
24 or
23 um I never was able to get a job that
made sense with my career what I
wanted so instead of going into a
direction of entertainment news reporter
or working at a huge production company
or working in some sort of film movie
capacity working in entertainment or
anything like that like I wanted I never
got any of those jobs so the first 5
years I graduated in 20 2015 so the
first 5 years of after my graduation it
was constantly looking for work and
constant looking for jobs I never got
them I never I had a few interviews but
I never got jobs I never got
jobs and it just nobody wanted to hire
me nobody wanted to give me
opportunities nobody wanted I I don't
know if they thought I was too dumb to
do the work they kept the thing I kept
getting was this is literally what I
keep getting today in my 33 years is you
don't have enough experience you don't
know what you're doing so we can't hire
you but it's like like well how am I
going to get experience if I don't if
you don't hire me and that's still the
struggle today which I will get into
later about the state of my job hood and
how I ended up having no Direction
that's exactly what it was like when I
got out of college it was constantly you
don't have a job you don't have enough
experience we can't hire you no job
nothing I wanted I applied for you know
companies like brick Co BuzzFeed Yahoo
like all their like fun media Department
jobs I applied for them nobody video I
applied for video editing jobs nobody I
went into the direction of getting a job
just to live which is which is fine
sometimes you do have to do that so I
ended up getting like retail jobs I got
um customer service job I got a sales
job like things like that even though it
wasn't really what I wanted I still
ended up getting those jobs I stayed in
those in that direction for a while and
and those were fine even though I knew
that it wasn't really what I wanted to
do and then at 25 I got married the
marriage did Last 5 Years which was
great but unfortunately it didn't work
out and there's the end of that I may
talk about that in another video but for
now that's where I was at 25 I got
married at
25 by the time I was 30 the marriage was
over and then I had to kind of restart
my life again so I ended up um moving
ended up moving across this um across
the state I was in San Francisco and
then now I moved down to Los Angeles in
the middle of Co and then last year
literally a year ago after I've was
looking and struggling and trying to
find work that I really liked I found a
job as a project manager at a tech
company and I was really scared when I
first started that job something about
the job didn't feel right but I I did it
anyway I I was really happy I had
everything I needed I was I had
insurance I was going somewhere with my
life even though I didn't have a
boyfriend or or a partner anymore I was
really happy because I was like I was
making good money and I was I had
friends I I was socializing I was I was
I was excited even though I in the back
of my head I knew something was wrong I
still kind of just went through my life
as best as I could about a year ago I
got fired which is how I'm in my
position right now about a year later is
because I got fired from that job and it
was really devastating and ever since
then I'm back to my college days or
early 20s where I'm having a hard time
finding a job I haven't been able to
find a good fulltime solid benefits all
those kinds of jobs in the corporate
realm I did get a few contract jobs um
right after I got fired but again there
were contract jobs they didn't that
means they didn't last they weren't
permanent they didn't have any benefit
but one job lasted 6 months and another
job lasted 2 months so I was able to
kind of cover my bills in that way it
feels like again that nobody wants to
hire me it feels like again that nobody
wants anything to do with me it feels
like and I'm still getting that same
thing I'm getting the same like you're
not good enough you don't have enough
experience we can't hire you you don't
have enough experience even though my
experience had demonstrates everything
on my resume they're still saying I
don't have enough experience for the job
so that's how I'm here now is I am 33 no
job no family living off of unemployment
I barely I could barely make ends me
thank goodness I don't have any children
I only have my cat to take care of but I
still struggle financially again I'm on
unemployment and food stamps I should
make clear that I'm on food stamp right
now I'm not happy because I'm I'm
struggling emotionally mentally I just
can't seem to get my life together so
I'm hoping that trying to create content
for YouTube and trying to put my story
out there will resonate with some people
that are probably feeling the same way
I'm feeling as far as where I'm going
I'm hoping to you know start creating
more content on YouTube and making more
videos and putting more time towards
something that really want to do versus
waiting for companies to tell me that
they don't want me or they don't want to
hire me and they don't want to work with
me and I'm not good enough because when
I'm doing YouTube and I'm doing my own
content I nobody's going to tell me that
nobody's going to say to me hey you're
not good enough you're fired you're not
good enough you're not you know you're
not worth it you're not worth the
investment nobody's going to tell me
that so I'm really hoping that going on
to some sort of video
production on YouTube will get me to
where I want to go mentally emotionally
financially and hopefully something will
come out of this even if it's just
knowing that somebody out there is going
through this and knows that they're not
alone when it comes to having a very
directionless life so that's that's what
I'm hoping to get out of this so you
might be wondering what I do all day
with now without having any sort of
Direction I spent a lot of my days
inside the house which sucks sometimes
but it's really nice to have peace I do
a lot of cooking I do a lot of cleaning
I shop a lot I'm always shopping for
like groceries or clothes or um when I
say clothes I mean more like window
shopping I'm not really out here like
buying bags or shoes or you know things
like that I do more window shopping the
other day I went to Ros Rod drive and
that was really fun um some days I get
really lonely but I
power through it by watching TV reading
my books I look for jobs all day every
day um that also kills time I talk to my
friends on the phone um things like that
so as as far as advice goes for young
people I think that everybody in their
life will have a time in their life
where they just don't know where they're
going and they don't have any control of
what life is bringing I I think that's a
thing I think that's possible in um
every young person or older person's
life you know some like you know when
women um when their children leave for
college and they're feeling you know
they they're empty nesters that's
something that feel very directionless
cuz you're like what do I do now that my
kids are out of the house you know when
you get fired and you have you have to
wait for your next gig as far as advice
goes what I would say is these three
things number one have a Sol solid good
support system know that there are
people in your life that you can go to
to talk to about anything and everything
no matter what time no matter what you
know where you are you can talk to them
always have something planned and
something to look forward to something I
do a lot of that I did a lot of this
year is I went to a lot of shows I was
able to go to a lot of my favorite shows
I saw Beyonce yes amazing so that was
something to look forward to um when the
Barbie movie came out I made sure to
plan an event with my friends and we had
a really good time because again I was
looking forward to that okay so my third
and probably final advice is knowing
that this phase of life is not permanent
and even though it feels permanent even
though it feels very long I'm assuming
that I'm not going to do this in like 5
years 5 to 10 years I may be like this
in the next year or two but knowing that
I won't be like this in 5 to 10 years is
kind of also so what keeps me going it
again it feels very permanent it feels
like crap I don't have a direction I
need help um it feels like that but it
at the end of the day I know in my head
that it's not even though my brain is
telling me like girl what are we doing
if I am here in the next 5 to 10
years I I need to real really
re-evaluate what is happening in my life
because that's a that's going to be a
huge problem if this video helped you in
any way shape or form please subscribe
like the video and I'm happy to kind of
go into more detail about more stuff and
where I am or where I'm going and I
would love to share more so just make
sure to subscribe and follow along with
me as I try my best to figure out this
life so what I thought of this video is
this is what what's next for modern
women MH I think there's going to be a
huge economy crash I think it's going to
leave a lot of women unemployed I I
don't think she's alone I think we're
already starting to see it I think it's
going to get worse especially in
America yeah I mean I think a video like
this is important because I think it's
perhaps the first step to resonating
with people to get people to realize
that perhaps we're making the wrong
decisions in my personal opinion I don't
think she said enough I don't think she
took enough accountability for her
circumstances oh to say that you are
you're you're not getting a job you know
she she did do the right steps she
didn't she didn't go on only fans so I
will give her that she did go and get
jobs in retail but it's like she seems
to be very adamant on the path of she
mentioned you know specific media jobs
very specific she hasn't tried anything
else and the way I see it if you are
unhappy with your life and you're
unhappy with the results that you've got
that means you need to try something new
so I think what she could have done is
perhaps tried a different career path
she had what sounded like you know most
people's degrees nowadays very broad
transferable skills that could have been
applied to anything second thing she's
saying that she applied to people like
BuzzFeed now they are most more than
likely I'm assuming one of the top
companies you can go for she could have
started with applying with something
else another thing I didn't hear from
her was offering to work for free and I
always say this to you know younger
people who are starting out um just as
as I you know I was very lucky um I was
willing to work for free I didn't have
to but you must be willing to work for
free if if you're not getting anywhere
and people are saying you've got no
experience you need to gain that
experience the only way you're going to
do that is making yourself worth their
time so if you say to an employer look
have you got a job they say no okay why
not well we need someone with this
experience blah blah blah blah blah okay
what if I come and work for you for free
for this amount of time and you train me
up and then if I'm competent enough for
you after say three months six months a
year then we negotiate a salary there
are things you can do to get somewhere
and unfortunately I don't think she's
done enough well I was even thinking her
editing skills are so bad that's what I
was thinking you're like youve had 10
years to learn how to edit like it's all
on YouTube as harsh as it sounds I was
thinking I could edit a little bit
better I mean I definitely could not my
SK no I know that's what I was going to
say I'm not even going no okay the other
thing I was I do appreciate her being
honest so I don't I'm not even trying to
like on her too much it's good that
it will resonate with people but but
what I kept hearing was the job was a
success if she got to make friends if
she had this work life balance I never
heard her talking about skills like if
you talk to me about media I I don't
even really talk about that I talk about
how excited I am for that project yes
because I really P like today right guys
I had this idea of I want to do an
American Idol talent show but for
YouTubers so if you want to apply DM me
on Instagram you got to be in London but
do you know what I mean like that's what
gets me excited because to me it's so
fun but she it doesn't even sound like
she's passionate about the job it's more
passionate about the status of the job
the kind of company is and the kind of
people and fun things she gets to do and
then the other thing she said I wasn't
given an opportunity and I'm think
create one that's exactly and said you
know I spend my days calling my friends
listening to music like how do you have
the money to do all of this stuff yeah
she went to a Beyonce concert yeah how
did you have the money to do that that's
I'm like why are you on food stups and
going to a Beyonce concert like clearly
not good money management her first
thing was window shopping well it's like
if you're window shopping you're going
to buy something inevitably what the
other then why are you shopping so I I
was thinking like when I was in I was in
Milwaukee um and I was working in sales
and I hated it and I didn't know what I
wanted to like do in life and I was
trying to figure it out and you know I
ended up messaging and like calling
Fortune like 500 SE level Executives and
I literally got like three to meet with
me I nothing like came out of it but I
was so amazed at how like willing people
are to help you when you just show
initiative and ask another thing I did
this was when I was um just wanting to
be a YouTuber and this didn't even want
a job but I wanted to see if I could get
a job just by going into rich
neighborhoods and go door too asking for
work AR remember be told me about this
yeah and I actually I got um a I mean I
didn't get a job offer because I would
have had to go in and apply and I just
didn't want to do all that you know I
don't want to waste their time yeah but
literally the recruiter like their head
recruiter called me because I knocked on
the door of like a big fortune or like a
big I don't know I guess he had a big
company around there I don't even know
and another thing I've not seen from her
and I I I say this to people all the
time younger people if you want to get a
job you need to get ahead of the game
everyone right now is implying on indeed
total jobs whatever everyone's trying to
do it online how many people these days
print off a CV and go in and ask for the
manager and shake their hand look them
in the eye and give them a smile you do
that you're not you're automatically
ahead of the game because not only have
they got your CV in front of them they
can't ignore it not like indeed where
they can just SW wipe off of it they've
got a face to the name they've got a
feeling from the interaction you have
like and people you so many people
aren't actually willing to do that
that's how I got my first sales job I
printed out I I moved to an area didn't
have a job no I had part-time jobs but I
wanted something full-time as well and I
printed out 10 CVS I found 10 estate
agencies that I thought I'd like to work
for and uh I walked in I said is your
manager here introduce myself this is my
CV I'm looking for work don't know if
you're hiring if they then said we're
not hiring at the moment I would say
okay can I get some experience can I
work here for a certain amount of time
and maybe then you think about hiring me
um but I I was very lucky after doing
all of that I got the call from the
first estate agency I walked into and
you know they were it takes a day like
that's it's so funny you said that cuz I
did the exact same thing every summer in
college all of my friends would be
applying online and I would just think
that's too much work let me just go door
too an hour out of my day and some yeah
and some people said no it happens but
it would never take me more than say
like a week to at least get an interview
and you're you're always ahead of the
game like that because in a world where
everyone's on the internet you know the
difference it makes shaking someone's
hand giving them a smile eye contact
having a conversation you're
automatically ahead of the game and the
other thing I noticed from this video
was it's like this is what's on the
other side ladies of divorce you know
now she's living on food stamps she's
clearly not good with money no and she's
unemployed in her apartment that's
another thing I didn't like you know
she's willing to talk about it just
shows where her priorities are at
because all she's talking about is the
career she just very quickly brushes
over a 5-year marriage no tell us tell
us more about what happened there I know
she said she was willing to to say more
so perhaps she does at some point but
you can't just make a video like that
and and not give the full story yeah
yeah and it was just kind of amazing to
me because this is what's going to
happen to so many chicks they're not
actually providing real value at her job
I I didn't hear any anything about her
pursuing skills no and I'm like I and
you know I actually think she's on the
right track I think she's going to do
well as a YouTuber I actually think she
will resonate with so many yeah and I
think there's some reward for being
honest you know and there's something
and she's I think I don't even think
that she's necessarily being I would
hope anyway I don't think she's
necessarily being willfully ignorant I
don't think she's I just don't think
she's come to the realization yet to
look back in hindsight and go maybe I
should have tried another area maybe I
should have moved outside maybe I should
have lowered my standards a bit maybe I
should have offered to work for free um
I think she actually is being as honest
as she can be right now I just think
hindsight's a and I think maybe a
year or two down the line she will come
to the revelation of the things that
we've just said um but like you say I
think she probably will do well on
YouTube because she is being honest I
she did seem pretty authentic I just
think it's a shame that maybe she didn't
have the people around her to say hey
lower your standards hey try something
new well and it's funny too cuz the same
thing happened to me with media like I
totally applied to the Daily wire Dave r
i I emailed Dave rubben like three
summers in a row about being an intern
yeah um I I you I emailed so many people
and actually what made my stuff you got
a try your luck what you've got to try
your life yeah and what what kind of
took everything off was um I mean you
know like my old manager basically what
happened was I I messaged him and asking
for YouTube advice and I was like hey I
see you work for the daily wire at the
time can you please give me advice and
that's how it started I was he he just
said he thought that I was talented he
thought that I was good and he said just
give me like an ad Revenue percentage
okay and then um like yeah and then we
worked something out and at the time it
was like I was making Zer so I was like
yeah go ahead but it worked out for him
you know of course yeah yeah yeah it's
interesting because that that's the
future for a lot of women there's going
to be a lot of homeless women and it
also showed that she's looking for a
bailout she's saying I need help men
don't get help women do she's on food
stamps which most women are on it's
mostly women on food stamps and this is
this is the one problem what is her what
would her life be like if there was no
bailout yeah exactly and this is the one
mistake the biggest mistake that mostly
women but a lot of young people will
will make in life it's putting all your
eggs in one basket and failing at the
first hurdle because we live in a
culture now where it's just so easy to
do that because of how many bailout
options there are because of how much
help that there is it's too easy for
people to just put all of their eggs in
the daily wires in the buzz feeds of the
world and go well if I don't get that
then I guess I'm stuck and then they can
rely on the help the best thing you can
do for yourself is no doubt give it a go
you can't not give it a go apply for the
daily wires apply for the buzz feeds
apply for the top companies but when it
doesn't work and chances are it won't
especially if you're young you need to
put your eggs in multiple baskets you
need to try different things don't tell
yourself that you know what you're going
to enjoy don't tell yourself I'm only
going to enjoy this field focus on
skills because skills are transferable
and try them in different things when
you are young you can afford to up
but when you are this woman and you are
in your 30s and you're in a situation
where you're homeless divorced and
unemployed yeah you're dealing with a
different cattle of fish and that's the
that's the thing if we can be honest and
say hey okay you want to live the rest
of your life alone let's actually
develop some real skills yes and then at
least you can pay for but my issue is
when people choose what they're going to
choose and they expect everyone else to
pay for it and when you could have
instead of spending your time at Beyonce
like imagine if she spent the time she
spent at Beyonce concerts online
training free courses she could love
everything's on you cannot tell me it's
not online I learned everything I know
online and I run a tighter immedia
company than most places I have gone to
everything you learn is online it's all
free it's all out there fre it's all out
there but you have to be willing to like
sift through the information 100% but
she wants to be given the opportunity um
I hope it let's look at the comments I
actually hope it works out for her
because I I really think it's important
that people are honest yes um you know
33 looking 20 I wouldn't say not knowing
what you want to do is bad thing I'm 25
in the same boat life is all about
experience we don't have it all together
I would say I'm a late bloomer I would
say that being Late Bloomer is very real
and that may become the norm I do think
that it's going to become the norm I
think you're even listening to her talk
she kind of sounded like a teenager yeah
yeah I'm 20 and dropped out of college
rice I feel pure dread about my future
but seeing how you are about this is
very relatable I think I'll be okay this
is very honest and makes me very
grateful guys it's only
okay how is she affording to live alone
it looked like it was her own apartment
don't know this is th this is what I'm
saying about the help you know you just
said that she comes across like a
teenager well the reason for that is
because of all the help yeah people
don't have to grow up anymore because
they they don't need to because if if
you can't look after yourself the state
will look after you yeah I'm thank you
for this I'm 27 almost 28 and I have to
move back in with my mom twice the past
year due to a failed relationship lack
of job opportunities and severe mental
health struggles this is only temporary
and you know what the other empathy I
have is is our generation was really
taught wrong MH like the women of our
age group were not taught this stuff
some were you know there's exceptions
but they don't make the rule nobody
taught us how to get into relationships
nobody taught us how to submit to their
husband most mothers actually sabotage
their daughter's relationships they and
I've even um like when I was reacting to
Tyrese Gibson's like exwife or whatever
he even said her mom sabotaged her
relation relationship this woman was
married to tall jacked handsome
millionaire and her mom sabotages her
you know the thing is they W have the
same options as they age and you know
what it happens when you age you get
wrinkled but a way to prevent this is
that one of the leading reasons skin
begins to Sag and form wrinkles is not
necessarily because of old age but
because our bodies are missing out on
essential collagen you see we produce
10% less collagen every decade once we
hit 30 and that's a major reason behind
those pesty wrinkles adding just a
little collagen to your diet has
noticeable effects for your skin and
your youthfulness preferably the sooner
the better that's why myself along with
tens of thousands of people have turned
to this Cutting Edge new substance to
help reduce visible signs of aging it
uses the top five most researched types
of collagen which is essential for our
skin Health to support skin elasticity
and skin hydration these five collagen
types are difficult to find on their own
but they're all included in each scoop
just mix your favorite serving with your
morning drink to give you the building
blocks you need to reignite a youthful
glow the best part I love is that you
get 53% off for the rest of the month or
until they sell out whatever comes first
plus you'll also receive additional
gifts valued at over $500 free with
every order for a limited time including
VIP live health and fitness coaching for
Life a free new ebook titled the 14
foods for amazing skin a 60-day
satisfaction guaranteed and free
shipping get yours now by going to
health withth pearl.com that's Health
withth pearl.com you will not regret it
so as I was saying before you know women
really do lead other women astray
correct and and so we used to be able to
go to our elders and get wisdom from
them so you know you could talk to the
50-year-old woman and she would say stay
in that marriage this is how you can
work it out don't do what I did correct
and that's one benefit that men have
that women don't men see themselves in
young men yeah so they actually want to
help them yeah where women see younger
women as competition that's so they lead
us astray now in times past the dad
would fix this because the dad would
actually look out for their daughter
yeah but now you have issues where
mothers will alienate the kid and say
all these bad things to the child about
the dad even if they're still married
this goes on a lot y um the other thing
that happens is the mom divorces the dad
or was never married to the dad to the
begin with and there's no male figures
in that person's life that can help them
no um so I saw an article from
Psychology today that says the 10
benefits of being single single people
have more time to use how they want they
can focus more they're in charge of
themselves they're not getting hurt life
is steady they are calm they can see
whomever they want they can use their
resources as they want to they're
excused from many undesirable couples
activities and they manage their own
eating
let's see the caption for this whether
by choice or circumstance singlehood
comes with opportunities that for some
make it quite appealing and this is
coming from Psychology today and it's
interesting because actually I'm going
to I'm going to give them their half
credit okay they make some points for
men okay but they don't for women these
things that they're talking about can be
helpful to Men I'm not saying but I do
think it's better for a man to be alone
than with a harlot and unfortunately
there are a lot of harlots on the market
today true but this is not the right
message for women because women are on
anti-depressants as they get older yeah
sure it is fun being single in your 20s
yeah but your 30s 40s and especially 50s
are a completely different animal you
don't have the friends you used to you
don't typically have the community you
used to you don't have a family and it's
very lonely and older women will
not even admit that to us um the
comments say provided you have a healthy
relationship many of these points are
incorrect I don't see any point of
encouraging singlehood in a society that
is already struggling with relationships
yeah that was that was going to be my
point biggest cope ever and Teresa has
written the same wretched PT article
every month for about five years we get
it you're single why not just live your
life rather than try to justify it to
everyone else yeah it it just seems a
bit uh narcissistic in its nature yeah
which is that other people are nothing
but objects to me and those objects must
bring value it ignores the whole point
of a human relationship in my opinion
and I don't I don't think it's good to
advise men or women that relationships
are bad I think we can be honest about
things especially with regards to men
and say look with the current dating
Market chances are that you know a woman
can have certain factors that might
indicate certain things are going to
happen just as we can for men but I
think at the for women but at the moment
it's definitely more men who need to be
warned yeah well women can control it
yeah like I I think that women really
dictate the relationship Market because
we get the most power when we're young
yeah so we can indicate we can dictate
the future of relationships how many
players were born because a young woman
broke his heart 100% yeah you know what
I mean I even um I think I'm not going
to say his name but I think of someone I
know pretty closely and he wanted
nothing but to be a traditional guy yeah
that was all he wanted he had one girl
he met in high school he wanted to marry
her and that she wanted to go be a
in college he got dumped now this man is
the biggest man
and that's you know that's that's
the one thing is players typically come
from Harlot women yeah and Men Women
choose to be lonely men do not no that's
true yeah because typically a woman can
get a guy to do traditional things
protect provide at at its Basics a man
can't magically get an 120 pound not ran
through uh childless chick you know so
it it's but it's unfortunate because
what they're pushing really Psychology
today you know women are the ones
reading
that yep I wonder who wrote that article
woman it's probably cat
lady without a doubt so um the other
thing we do now on Pearl daily is I read
the top comment from the last show oh
cool yeah so guys if you want your
comment to be read next show make sure
that you hit the like button on your
favorite comment below and leave your
comment GG the backyard herbalist says I
pray for the day when women can be
ladies wives mothers and homemakers
without being looked down upon it's the
most important job for women be proud of
being a wife and a mother mother yes
because women are so influenced by
culture and right now we have no women
in the culture there's no role models
who I mean they're all none yeah and the
culture that we see on TV I hate to say
it does reflect Society in some way AB
because the people do Elevate that
people can relate to absolutely like we
saw with that YouTuber earlier yeah guys
thank you so much for watching thank you
Christine for coming on thank you for
having me tell the people where they can
find you yeah you can check me out on
YouTube at Christine Grace Smith I've
got a reaction series that's currently
Ono um also check out my series
debunking The lunacy where I give my
in-depth analysis to show you the flip
side of the media the things that they
don't want you to know the things that
they don't want us talking about but
we're going to talk about it anyway so
yeah go check it out and you're on
Twitter too now oh yeah I'm on Twitter
too Christine Grace X is my my Twitter
I'm uh I'm still getting familiar with
it so I'm not tweeting as much as say po
does yet but I'll get you're getting the
hang of it you're getting the hang of it
guys like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and we'll talk
to you next
time